crossovers
when hypothetical what-ifs come to life
in gaming
crossovers allow for some of the coolest
and most hilarious combinations of
franchises
that otherwise have nothing to do with
each other like the pokemon incineroar
fighting the animal crossing villager in
a boxing ring
[Applause]
wow that was weird anyway let's take a
look at the top 10 crossovers in esports
starting us off is the one thing that
ties every moba together
the fact that every one of these games
features an army of
warcraft knockoffs the original dota was
a mod of warcraft 3 of course so
naturally it used warcraft character
models
there were some changes to their lore
and background like the character of
malfurion being renamed to the
brilliantly original furion but
that's about it that's the best you can
do but in dota 2
while the heroes largely stayed the same
names with explicit references to
warcraft would change
so val didn't get their asses sued by
blizzard but the crossovers didn't stop
there
league of legends clash of fates
league of legends early days were led by
a bunch of former
dota devs and some early champs share a
striking resemblance to
older dota heroes want to ride around
the map in a floating machine like
gyrocopter
try corki a fan of pudge's hooks locking
blitzcrank
and some characters even trace their
crossover lineage
all the way back to warcraft do you like
ash
well here's her mom drow ranger and
here's grandma sylvanas all the way back
in 2002. the best part of this crossover
is that it came full circle in 2015 when
blizzard released heroes of the storm
which basically took a whole bunch of
dota characters
back to their warcraft origins hey it's
not stealing if you're taking it back
right come join us in the nexus and
experience a new
kind of moba
taking the number nine spot on our list
is maybe the most ambitious crossover
event
in history oh my god i get to be thanos
again
suck on that everyone else at this point
fortnite has crossed over with
pretty much everything from batman to
the nfl
but nothing has been a bigger deal or
more important to the game
than their crossovers with marvel the
first crossover came in 2018
coinciding with the release of infinity
war where players
literally got to laser enemies as thanos
wreaking
havoc with the utterly broken super
villain oh i'm gonna wreck him
so what is it i do that and then
oh my god that is disgusting since then
marvel and fortnite have kept crossing
paths we had another thanos event in
2019
a truly absurd amount of marvel skins i
mean who the hell
even is psylocke and most recently
galactus
ate fortnite's island to launch a whole
new season
this collaboration is truly the
fortnight gift that keeps on giving
taking number eight on our list is
mortal kombat's truly bizarre obsession
with
80 cinema you ever go on a classic
action movie binge and think
i wish i could see rambo fight magical
monster warriors with superhuman
abilities where he could become the
ruler of space and time
because i know i sure haven't but the
folks over at
nrs did adding 80s action stars rambo
terminator and robocop to mortal kombat
11.
haven't we done this before i have no
record of a previous encounter
we have met i
this isn't the first time they've done
this either mortal kombat x featured a
whole bunch of iconic horror film
baddies
including jason voorhees predator alien
and leatherface and she only needs one
bar to get out of this situation
now let's hope 90s comedies are the next
genre netherrealm chooses for a
crossover
could you actually imagine mrs
doubtfire's fatality
for now though there's nothing quite
like seeing robocop mercilessly
slaughter an immortal ninja
and then take a whole bunch of selfies
[Music]
coming in at number seven it's my time
friends
smite has had some very very weird
crossovers over the years but in 2020
they really tried to make a grab for the
zoomers with this
they need our help
fans could now rp as the baddest avatar
in smite with
ang korra and zuko skins coming to the
game via battle pass
these skins were so cool it actually got
people coming back to the game
just to try it like youtuber mr fruit
here today is literally the day
i i played smite 4. that is because
as you see here the avatar the last
airbender skins
are officially in the game the crossover
was a hit
and with just how gorgeous the skins
look in game it left community members
like solo double j
pretty impressed this skit is really
well done holy [ __ ]
all the effects are just so nice dude
that would look so cool oh i'm impressed
coming in at number six on our list is a
crossover of tom clancy titles in
rainbow six siege and splinter cell
you should know better than write me off
he looks so cool now as far as gaming
crossovers go
this is a match made in heaven there's
few characters in gaming
more suited to be an operator in siege
than sam
fisher it's literally his day job i'm
just watching him yeah
he's like i'm just observing him in his
natural habitat all right keep an eye on
him he's still there
i'll pick him for he's looking looking
looking down you never lose
dude this opera is i'm telling you he's
so good for [ __ ] like that
despite becoming an operator sam
fisher's kit is still filled with
splinter cell callbacks
including his primary weapon and
equipment which both come from splinter
cell
his sc 3000k assault rifle may look
familiar to fans of his previous work
and it's right at home in siege with a
variety of optics to suit your preferred
style
now all that's left is for this amazing
crossover to make its way into pro play
marking the halfway point on our list is
akuma in tekken 7.
the first crossover character to join
tech and seven's cast of fighters
akuma was more than just a fun piece of
fan service to mess around with
he broke the rules of tekken introducing
new mechanics that
changed the game forever oh here it is
oh here we go why did you say that mark
i wanted to see point
oh my god look at the hell and
[Applause]
[Music]
akuma brought his super meter and focus
attack dash cancel from street fighter
to tekken
forcing players to rethink how they play
the game when matched up against him
a lot of the players even some of the
best koreans were just
very unfamiliar with the match-up
and lojai trying to play shahi is
shaheen vs akuma
but you could see the struggle and the
difficulty of dealing with the demon
flip for example
as the main man mentioned super akuma
was one of the first players to show
just how strong akuma was but it wasn't
until 2019 when pakistan made their huge
splash into the tekken scene
that the true power of this crossover
character became known
malaysia now tekken has seen other
crossover characters since
from broken characters like geese to
underplayed low tiers like noctis
but all of them have brought unique
interesting mechanics from their own
games
into tekken just like akuma well except
for negan
that dude just swings his back
coming in at number four we've got a
cheeky little crossover from the fps
world
there are a few guns in gaming more
recognizable than the orb
counter-strike has made the york an
iconic symbol of snipers in
all of esports with a gun producing
untold numbers of
legendary esports moments and there is a
shot that just runs right into him
oh my god no way that just happened
coldzera eat your heart out
oh he's got a third nitro slamming down
the gauntlet
so when riot games were making their
tactical shooter they did their best to
recreate csgo's premier sniper
even down to the name may i present to
you valorance operator sniper rifle
otherwise known as the op that's op
get it
what and following in the footsteps of
his older brother
valerian's op was already deemed too
powerful for the game after guys like
wardell got their hands on it
receiving a slew of nerfs now whether
you're happy or angry that riot
commandeered this crossover
you've got to admit that the name is
kind of cute i mean
all up come on
coming in at number three we have league
of legends crossover with
kpop now if you think riot games is a
game studio
you're wrong i'm sorry the company is
actually a record label
and they proved that in 2018 with the
introduction of the group kda
kda is a virtual girl group composed of
a bunch of league champs
now they aren't real they're just skins
but ryan got a bunch of actual musicians
including real k-pop stars to record the
fake band's debut single for
worlds 2018
[Applause]
[Music]
the song exploded hitting 13 million
views on youtube in 48 hours
the world couldn't get enough of kda
this crossover got so big
it transcended league of legends itself
and pop stars reached number one on
billboard's world digital song sales
chart
and kda has only gotten bigger in 2020
the group released a whole ep featuring
more huge names
including mega girl group twice now
please
just cool it a little bit with the kda
content right some of these videos are
getting
really weird probably got a job kylie go
to work
always on fire don't get burnt i try not
to get burned
but it's not always easy when you're
spitting hot flames
our runner-up spot goes to the character
that turns smash bros into gaming's most
ridiculous crossover
solid snake there's probably not a
single person who doesn't know mario
he's that famous good thing i survived
long enough to meet him on the field
battle huh
snake was the first non-nintendo
character to appear in smash bros
announced all the way back in 2006
but snake doesn't exactly fit into
nintendo's cartoon
kid-friendly world he's a grizzled war
veteran who could choke out pikachu
and hit mario in the face with a
claymore on the other hand
snake ushered in a whole new era of
third-party crossovers in smash
he led to characters like sonic
bayonetta cloud and
minecraft steve this sucks
i hate it no
and taking our top spot is none other
than the shotokan master himself
ryu i mean there's making a statement
and then there's just
going ham that's that that is
what is he doing i think he's like he's
going for the record do we have
do our record keepers have the most
consecutive dragon punches in a row can
we get those numbers please now you
might not realize it but ryu has
appeared in more different video game
franchises than basically
any other character first of all he's
been in all
of capcom's own crossover fighting games
including
marvel vs capcom snk vs capcom
and tatsunoko vs capcom he also found
himself fighting the mashima family in
street fighter cross tekken oh yeah and
he's also in super smash bros too
so this is smash come on
but ryu doesn't just cross over to other
fighting games the guys become a leader
in the card game
shadowverse and entered a ton of popular
gatcha games including monster strike
he even became a power ranger for god's
[Music]
sake
all right guys those were some of our
favorite crossovers in esports and now
i'm gonna ask you to hit the subscribe
button if you haven't done so already
we are on the road to two million
subscribers we're really excited
we hope that you can help us get there
thanks for watching and i'll see you all
in the next video so the crazy thing
about ryu
is that he's crossed over into so many
games that you can get to him from
any famous person or celebrity in
six or less steps i've got a few here
martha stewart
right she's friends with snoop dogg
snoop dogg is in tekken tag tournament
two
with kazuya now kazuya is in street
fight across tekken
with ryu there you go that wasn't even
six so martha stewart is only
three degrees of separation from ryu